one thing about this movie that makes me
really happy is as much as i love dr
strange i'm so happy that you are back
in this horror realm right now so a
twofold question for you on that what is
something about your experience working
on a gigantic mcu project that you found
influencing how you operate on a set
like this but then what's something
about making a movie like black phone
that i guess kind of felt like coming
home to you where you were so excited to
tap back into that particular quality of
making a movie like this
i mean look i uh you know from the heart
i had an amazing experience working on
doctor strange um but when you're making
a movie that size uh for marvel you
really are working with uh you know with
kevin feige you're really co-making the
movie with him and you're working
there's a lot of people creating you
know giving influence into the process i
felt very supported making that movie i
made the movie i wanted to make but it's
different than when you're talking about
a smaller
uh contained horror film because then
you really function like an auteur
it's all on you and jason blum is the
greatest producer you know on both
sinister and this movie all he did was
just say whatever you need
make the movie you want to make and so
it was all up to me and uh and in both
cases i made exactly the film i wanted
to make the funny thing about it though
is that
every you know sinister was three
million dollars this movie was 18. uh
doctor strange was over 200 million
they're all the same you never have
enough time or money you know you always
have the same problem i need more time i
need more money you know it doesn't
matter what the budget is oh i would
believe it all right so one of my
favorite qualities of this movie is
usually i get very obsessed with
backstory but you managed to keep a lot
about the grabber the phone itself and
also gwen's ability i mean not
necessarily secret but you don't explain
it away so is that something where you
could feel out in the script phase that
you're giving the audience enough or is
it a matter of you know needing to keep
an eye out for something like that in
test screenings i you know
look we did test screenings and a lot of
the test screening audiences said we'd
like to know more about the grabber and
so there was some pressure put on to me
to write some more about the grabber and
i refused i said i want them to want to
know more about the grabber i want them
to feel that way but trust me if i give
them more
the grabber will not be as scary i mean
how scary would the joker be in chris
nolan's dark knight if we actually
explained exactly what how he did get
his scars if we did that he'd be less
scary if we explained why hannibal
lecter eats people he would be less
scary you know and so i think with these
sort of anti-social really aggressive
really bizarre
fascinating villains
there's mystery to evil there's
and keeping it mysterious as to why they
do the extreme things that they do
allows the audience to infer
possibilities and to think for
themselves and keeping it mysterious
just makes them more frightening i could
not agree more i think you pulled that
quality off quite well here another
thing i appreciated about the film is i
am obsessed with sinister and it did
feel like it had echoes of that movie so
were those things you deliberately
strove to do and when you think about
this world is it the kind of situation
where i don't know you envision this
taking place in a town or a state over
kind of thing
i don't see them in the same universe
but certainly you know we got the band
back together i got i got you know my
writing partner cargill and ethan and
jason blum and and pj ranson as you know
is all all these sort of similar things
the use of super 8 footage you know
which i used for the for the kill films
in sinister
i used for very different purposes in
this
which was to
represent the dreams of the
kind of backstories or back story images
of some of the of the dead kids in the
movie um so there's some stylistic
overlap but i do think that at the heart
you know sinister is a very bleak
not a mean-spirited movie but it's a
very bleak and very ruthless movie you
know looking at uh
at um the consequences of of of selfish
ambition
and in this movie i wanted to make
something from the point of view of love
and i wanted to make something that was
very suspenseful and very scary but that
also was um
full of
uh love and and hope and
humor
and ultimately i think a kind of
inspiration it's certainly the most
positive movie i've ever made
above and beyond one of my favorite
qualities you terrify me but you give me
those feelings of hope too that is one
heck of a balance to pull off
congratulations oh thank you so much i
appreciate it
you